hello reject do you think supports its
habit I can't might be a lot a little
bit out of focus we can like prop this
up a little more to make sure it's easy
for you to sit up there you go my
specialty hi guys I'm Greg with me hit
or miss movies Brianne brie I'm really
you slap your chest Oh anyway we're
gonna watch this trailer this red band
trailer several people sent this in I am
red like a headline on Collider I have
about I know anything about apparently
this is like a horror film that is like
receiving a lot of recognition okay it's
called raw I think you might deal with
cannibalism I think it might deal with
the food industry and when things aren't
cooked to the right temperature what C
is correct let's find out oh my god I
hope there's something if there's
cannibal with maybe it's combined
temperature aberrant behavior grisly
images Oh nudity oh man and this is red
band
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Oh No
[Music]
I'm already not gonna see this
[Laughter]
[Music]
the neon demon yeah Cannibal Holocaust
[Music]
is going on
[Music]
no no scissors should never be anywhere
near there like stinger then they should
just cut that out and just done with the
scissors and the peeling and then that
would have been fine I don't even know
if I could sit through this I'm not
seeing this I don't think I can sit
through this if there's not a camera
recording me for a reaction then there's
no point to me watching dude that looks
like visceral and incredibly disturbing
that was very close to both cannibalism
also with neon demon neon demon yeah I
mean there's like two two things going
on they're physical scissors and
potentially a lesbionic relationship so
well she's also sleeping with a dude
she's beating on him at the end you know
and he's like petting her okay let's
read the plot description on it let's do
it
when a young vet vegetarian undergoes a
carniverous coniferous carnivorous yes
we were learning with courtesy easing
ritual at that school and unbidden taste
for meat begins to grow in her oh so she
starts like craving flesh so it's like
this lady's current hey I mean we saw oh
yeah know what it all really consists of
with the rituals like like are they
eating human fingers it looked like they
were taking stuff from animals and like
jumping in on them and everything I got
the beginning of that trailer I guess
it's not cannibalistic well it
definitely starts getting cannibalistic
this looks like one of those movies
that's it's real like it's I feel like
it's gonna escalating Lee get worse and
worse and worse as it progresses but it
also looks like a psychological
deterioration of this one woman yes who
just keeps going it's your dream
yeah exactly you know this is like what
is happening while she's taking the
final yeah because she's gone into this
craze it's one of those films that looks
so disturbing kind of sexually
captivating at the same time like it's
got all these different elements in
there where it's like that sexual
discomfort because that's definitely
their like dark sexuality it's like I'm
weirdly pulled into films like this
where this is disturbing
eerie off-putting but it seems like it's
gonna be so good at doing what its
setting out to do that I'm gonna kind of
enjoy the film for what it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
god only knows what's going on in that
[ __ ] Caesars business like they're
peeling so much flesh in the trailer
like even though it's even disturbing
when she's just scratching herself along
yeah does he keep imagine her skins is
gonna come off at one point the our
ratings shows that it's it's gonna be
like truly there all the vices
that's our okay got it for aberrant
behavior I thought that the this trailer
is rated R no no no that means the
movies right okay that's the movies PG
it could be nc-17 yeah it has this eerie
tone but this the visual cinematography
of it all also looks really well done to
like you said jaan-e-mann it does have
kind of that wooden ref and sort of vibe
about it it has a pretty pretty Sheen to
it yeah who's the julia reneau me French
French people man they're the best
there's a bad the best I'm making creepy
snow this is like her feature film debut
because it looks like she's done in 83
yeah what am i doing with my life
can you make stuff like this Fran French
filmmakers are not afraid to go all-out
like when it comes to like disturbing
stuff they don't hold back and they
what's cool about that is they can make
it artistic at the same time I feel like
that's probably this film is garnering a
lot of praise at the same time because I
get the sense that's more than just you
know creepy disturbing cannibal stuff I
feel like that's probably gonna have
these artistic elements in there as well
also thank whoever sent this in there
are several people who watch erotic
scenes that are gonna get violent those
are the most disturbing to me any time I
see that in a movie think like something
as simple as the bathtub scene in The
Shining with the old lady or like any of
American Horror Story season 5 or a
[ __ ] Lars von Trier film weird scary
about them it's like they're passionate
they're are graphic sex scenes you're
like don't get turned on right now
don't get turned on because something
horrible is gonna happen and it just
kills it oh man yeah this looks like it
could be one hell of a disturbing time I
might watch it yeah bro watch the film
reaction any tools that are down by my
business like no no it's like they don't
show you what's gonna happen right but
you can imagine a good trailer what did
you guys think of the trailer do you
like it you must have some of your
recommending it you can subscribe today
I would appreciate it my friend
I would especially appreciate if you
went over to brianne's channel
hit-or-miss movies six degrees of
feature film I was on an episode that
with John with the lovely beautiful
Stacy Howard and the lovely beautiful
Brienne and I also did film therapy with
Brienne she gave me a therapy session
co-pay was 35 bucks I'm not a real
therapist but I'll say but I paid her
insurance I called him like Ken can I
see her she charged me out-of-pocket why
don't you put it on the inner head
Oh Darrin how did I break that
patient-doctor confidentiality